[Music]
I'm working with the dating site
chemistry comm which is a division of
match.com
and I've put a questionnaire on that
dating site and five million people have
taken that questionnaire anyway about
12,000 people take that questionnaire
every week and so about a month ago I
put an intimacy scale onto that dating
site to see whether there's some gender
differences and whether different types
of personalities regarded intimacy as
differently and I found no gender
difference on two questions one of 95%
of both men and women agreed that they
felt it was extremely intimate to go off
and do something adventurous with their
partner and 95 percent agreed men and
women that having a deep intimate having
a deep conversation about the
relationship was intimate so I'm
beginning to think that we don't
understand men anymore than we
understand women as a matter of fact you
know men fall in love faster than women
do because they're so visual men are
more dependent on their girlfriends and
wives because they've got fewer intimate
connections with other men men are
two-and-a-half times more likely to kill
themselves when a relationship is over
and men are more likely to remarry after
a spouse has died or deserted them so I
think as we come to understand women I
think we are also going to come to
understand men there's one difference in
intimacy between men and women that I
think that comes out of our evolutionary
past women tend to get intimacy out of
face-to-face talking we swivel until we
are right in front of each other we
authorize with what is called the
anchoring gaze and we talk and we regard
that as intimate and men tend to sit
side by side and look straight forward
and not look at each other at all and
regard that as intimate and I think they
both come from our evolutionary past I
think women's intimacy comes from
millions of years of holding that baby
in front of your face controlling it
reprimanding it educating it with words
and so words and face-to-face contact is
intimate to
or is I think for millions of years men
had to sit behind a bush on the
grasslands of Africa and keep their eye
on that the grasslands hoping a zebra is
going to come by so that they can hit it
in the head with a rock and they can't
be sitting there talking with somebody
like this they've got to talk while
they're looking forward and I think this
can complicate relationships you know
you'll see a man and a woman on a park
bench and the man is talking looking
straight ahead and the woman has moved
every single part of her body around in
order to to have eye contact matter of
fact I've had various men in my life who
talked to me with our eyes completely
shocked and I think it's because it's
probably too intimate for them I mean
for millions of years men face their
enemies they really sat side by side
with friends so one of the things that I
do with the man to make him comfortable
is sit side by side with them and look
straight ahead
particularly if I'm going to have a
difficult conversation with them
I've looked at the dog tree in 42
societies and you see it every single
place even in cultures where you can get
your head chopped off for it so there's
every reason to think that we've got
some biological propensities
for it now people say no to adultery we
don't have to be an odorous but it's
remarkable how many people are and the
newest data is that in people under age
40 women are just as adulterous as men
and so I suspect that the last 10,000
years of keeping women in the kitchen
and the and the the home has and the
very strict rules against female
adultery in many societies has curbed
female adultery so that we think that
only men do it but the bottom line is
that every single time there's a man who
was sleeping around he is quite often
sleeping around with a woman and so just
doing the math and you begin to assume
that women are probably just as
adulterous as men but I actually think
that men and women are in sort of
collusion about this men want to think
that men are more adulterous than women
and I think that women want men to think
that men are more adults than women so
we've we've got ourselves believing that
men are more notice there's a great deal
of data over the last Oh data goes back
to the 1920s anyway
that men are more adulterous and what's
interesting is that the degree of
adultery hasn't changed a great deal in
the in the today the indication is for
the general population about a third of
men will be a dotrice at some point
during their marriage and about 15% of
women will be adulterous at some point
during their marriage and but as I say
among people under the age of 40 it
seems to be the same amount from women
as well as men
I don't think a person is always a
cheater now there's always variations
here
I studied personality types and the kind
of person who is very expressive of the
dopamine system I called them the
Explorer
they tend to be novelty seeking
risk-taking curious creative
spontaneously generous they're the kind
of a walk into a barn buy everybody a
drink
irreverent they don't follow the rules
unless they make sense for them quite
liberal very adaptable and flexible and
I would guess that this particular
personality type would be more inclined
to adult rain however when you find the
right person I would just as a lot of
people who've been adulterous for a good
deal of their lives and then they get
tired of it they find the really the
right person for them the kind of person
that'll get off the couch and go
straight to Saudi Arabia on a vacation
or straight to Ireland for a particular
Song Festival or they finally find
somebody who can play as hard and fast
and is as sexual as they are and or they
find somebody who they respect so much
that they don't want to risk it I do
think people change you know people some
people have a tendency towards
alcoholism and they give up drinking
some people certainly have a tendency
towards smoking cigarettes and they give
up cigarettes some people succeed in
giving up gambling or or losing weight
we do all kinds of things with our lives
that we biologically might not be
inclined to do and I think adultery is
one people can give up adultery however
I do think that this evolved this
restlessness in long relationships
evolved and we do as a species have a
tendency towards adultery
[Music]